next on c-span live from the awesome
tacular press room the fate of the
furious press conference with Vin Diesel
I mean it just feels like yesterday we
were starting production on the first
movie but here we are 16 years later
it's really humbling so at this point
I'm gonna open it up for questions so
would you say that you're still furious
or you're mad or perhaps you're just a
bit angry no I think we really up the
Furious this time oh but not so much
fast
of course the fast is still there fasten
what got us here so is it more fast or
more furious
what um okay I guess furious what
happened to the fast it's still there
okay next question
oh that isn't whether the movie is fast
or furious or vice-versa is the rock
coming no Jason Statham Terri's that was
Tokyo Drift so what about the rock I
already said no today
hey come on
so is this movie still about family it's
always been about family okay good and
how would you say the amount of family
in this film compares or contrasts to
the amount of fast versus furious in the
previous films I snuck in then I got a
questioning so I noticed in this one
you're finally riding a torpedo like a
skateboard on the ice while being chased
by a submarine in the North Pole so just
wanna know like what took you so long
you have to make it work you can't just
do wild stunts to do wild stunts riding
the torpedo was key to the story so more
key to the plot then when you jump the
cars from building to building in Dubai
well which kind of leads me back to the
question of does riding a torpedo make
this film more fast and furious than the
last film with jumping cars from
building the building or are both stunts
the equal amount of fast and furious
I'd imagine on the same level ice
skating on torpedoes building jumping
with cars it all kind of evens itself
out I was wondering whose idea where
Charlize Theron braided dreadlocks
mm-hmm
are you saying why women can't have
dreadlocks yeah have you seen my own
flux yeah she was in it yeah sure
what'd you think hey I thought we were
talking about the fate of the furious an
important question okay here we go
mister diesel what say you to the many
reports that have surfaced from Dwayne
the rock Johnson's Instagram feed
claiming a beef between the two of you
you say that these movies are all about
family but how can you be a family on
screen when off screen Dewayne the rock
Johnson promises to check you in to
Hotel de la SmackDown
my sources tell me that you are too
afraid to get off your Apple box to
confront doing the rock Johnson in
person and that you don't have a work
ethic I heard from a PA who overheard
someone mentioned to a grip that you
like to take naps and that the way the
rock Johnson hates you you're a sad
troubled and little dude
so are you confirming that you will not
fight the way in the rock Johnson at
WrestleMania and you answer the question
sir mr. diesel get back get back here
mr. Dees Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Applause]